what is going on everybody welcome to
part 15 of our Python with PI QT for the
creation of GUI application tutorial
videos series in this video we're gonna
be talking about how we can actually
save the stuff that we have put into our
editor so that will kind of bring our
little application of editing at least
to completeness so the first thing that
we want to go ahead and do is we need
just like we had an open file we need to
save file so let's go ahead and make one
of those we'll just copy that paste
instead of open file it's save file copy
that paste paste paste instead of
control oh it's ctrl s set it open it's
save sort of open file again it's save
instead of file underscore open it'll be
file on our score save then the only
other thing we need to add is right here
file menu add action open file we just
add action save file easy-peasy
next we'll come on down to file open
area we'll just put it right here and
now define file save again we pass the
obligatory self and then we're going to
say name equals QT gooey queue file
dialogue dot get save file name pass in
self and then the title to the window
will be save file then we're going to
say file a equals as same as before
open name only this time our intention
is to write we definitely want to write
because that's going to overwrite the
whatever the contents are initially so
write to that file then we're going to
say text equals self dot text edit dot
to plain text now what this is going to
do is it will convert the stuff that's
in our text editor basically the text to
plain text and that way it's just plain
text so we can save it to the file it
doesn't come with any other attributes
to the text that kind of are a part of
the QT kind of organization stuff
so then we're just going to say now file
dot write text and then file dot close
and it should be as simple as that
we'll find out if I've made any mistakes
but let's save and run it so here we
have this let's change to plastique
because I like it
file open file let us let's make a copy
of a Wow before we start editing these
files I want to save these files uh-uh
so I'm gonna copy PI Q T 15 and I'm
gonna call it edit me so here we go
let's rerun the application file open
file we're gonna open edit me and there
she is
beautiful as ever and now we're going to
do is instead of open sis we're going to
open XYZ now ctrl s to save awesome and
now we could save it as something new if
we want to like we could say it is
something new just like I said and
wouldn't you know it there is something
new didn't have any attributes but we
can open it with notepad and bam done
awesome also we can overwrite a file and
let's see how it handles such an action
so save file and we're going to try to
overwrite edit me and we even get this
little confirmation that hey do you sure
you really want to do this we're gonna
say yeah and that's done then we can
come back to edit me open it up with
idle sure enough XYZ awesome so now you
have a editor that actually works and it
was done mostly with widgets from QT so
that's pretty cool next what I want us
to talk about is the QT designer so as
you've seen up into this point QT comes
with a bunch of widgets that we can use
and it saves us a bunch of time well it
turns out the QT designer also saves us
a ton of time in GUI development so up
until this point we've kind of ignored
the notion of layouts with QT because
for pretty much all UI related things
you really should be using the QT
designer now of course we know we added
some buttons and we did
menu bar just so you understood how that
code works but moving forward once you
have a basic understanding of how the
code works for the creation of
everything UI which is user interface
for all of that you're going to want to
use the QT designer it just makes a lot
of sense to be using that instead so the
way it works is you start with a little
window here and you can add stuff to it
by basically click and drag right so you
can click and drag boom radio button
done you can rename the radio button
done you can add menus by you know here
and then you type menu and boom done you
can add more menus add separators all
kinds of stuff and it's so fast so
anyways that's what we're going to be
talking about in the coming tutorials so
stay tuned for that as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time